et dès qu'ils répliquent à faire elle
était en gros plan bon c'est pas le
flatte pas du tout j'ai expliqué que les
répliques
on s'en souvient beaucoup mieux quand on
roule et projette à la face que quand
vous entendez au lointain
alors ça c'est à dire facteurs l'autre
facteur c'est que ça fait rire tout
était écrit tous les plans étaient
écrits tous les gestes et écrit la larme
de lefebvre qui coule elle est écrite il
a fallu à faire au bon moment tout tout
tout tout les mouvements de caméra et
puis on avait un texte d'audiard on
n'avait pas à dire aux acteurs
improvisés ce soir la copie sera projeté
en noir et blanc avec lautner et avec
l'un des derniers temps on qui
aujourd'hui encore fait sa promo bp sont
exceptionnelles et comédiens etc cela
[Musique]